it’s a real crowd-pleaser.
♪
JEDEDIAH: WITH NEARLY 25 YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE, MORE THAN 550
RESTAURANT LOCATIONS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, TODD THE GRAVES OF
RAISING CAIN WANTED TO TAKE HIS
RESTAURANT FORWARD.
LAWRENCE: HE GETS TO DO JUST
THAT WITH A LITTLE HELP FROM
FAMOUS FRIENDS.
>> BECAUSE OF THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC, RESTAURANT OWNERS ARE
STRUGGLING LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
>> I’M HERE TO PAY IT FORWARD.
THAT’S WHY I’M HERE TODAY.
WITH THE HELP OF SOME FAMOUS
FRIENDS --
>> IT’S A PLEASURE TO MEET YOU,
LADIES.
IT’S A FAMILY-OWNED BUSINESS AND
WE’RE HERE TO SHOW YOU SOME
SUPPORT.
>> I THINK YOU JUST DID.
>> TO TRANSFORM THEIR RESTAURANT
FOR A NEW NEW YORK I’M GOING TO
NEED THOSE KEYS IN JUST 48
HOURS.
PETE: HELP OF SOME REALLY FAMOUS
FRIENDS.
>> FOUNDER AND CEO OF RAISIN
CAIN ALONG WITH ONE OF THOSE
VERY FAMOUS FRIENDS, ACTOR ROB
SCHNEIDER.
I’VE GOT TO SAY, TOM, I’LL START
WITH YOU, LAWRENCE JONES HAS
BEEN SINGING THE PRAISES OF YOUR
RESTAURANT THE, RAISIN CAIN.
YOU’VE GOT A BIG FAN HERE.
>> THE CAIN SAUCE IS, MY
FAVORITE.
>> I LOVE IT.
I LOVE MY CAINIACS OUT THERE.
PETE: TELL THE US ABOUT WHAT
YOU’RE DOING FOR SMALL BUSINESS.
>> YEAH, WELL, DURING THE
PANDEMIC MY SALES ACTUALLY WENT
UP BECAUSE WE HAD THE
DRIVE-THROUGH.
IT DIDN’T FEEL SO GOOD BECAUSE
WE WERE TAKING IT FROM THESE
INDEPENDENT FAMILY RESTAURANTS.
I’VE DONE SOME TV BEFORE,
UNDERSTAND THE POWER OF IT, SO I
HIRED A PRODUCTION TEAM AND
CREATED RESTAURANT RECOVERY.
LAWRENCE LAWRENCE WOW, TODD --
>> I WAS JUST THERE TO EAT.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THEN TODD WAS THERE.
TODD REALLY CARES ABOUT THE
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW?
HE CARES ABOUT FOOD MOST BUT
PEOPLE SECOND.
AND THESE PEOPLE WERE STRUGGLING
IN THEIR RESTAURANT, AND
THEY’RE -- I MEAN, THE STUFF
THAT THEY GOT FROM PAKISTAN,
THIS WONDERFUL, BEAUTIFUL FOOD.
YOU JUST, IT’S THEIR HEART AND
SOUL FOR 25 YEARS, AND TO SEE
THEM STRUGGLING AND TAKING MONEY
OUT OF THEIR POCKET EVERY WEEK,
TODD WAS TELLING ME ABOUT THESE
LOVELY PEOPLE.
AND TO GIVE THEM A CHANCE TO GET
BACK TO JUST BREAKING EVEN AND
MAKE SOME MONEY, IT JUST BROUGHT
TEARS TO THEIR EYES BECAUSE
THEIR HOPES AND THEIR DREAMS,
THE KID PUT HIS LIFE ASIDE TO
HELP HIS MOM IN THE RESTAURANT.
YOU CANNOT HELP BUT EMOTIONALLY
INVOLVED WITH THESE PEOPLE.
AND TODD REALLY WAS ABLE TO MAKE
A DIFFERENCE FOR EACH OF THESE
RESTAURANTS.
IT WAS GREAT TO BE PART OF IT.
JEDEDIAH: WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
CLIP9 FROM THE DISCOVERY PLUS
SERIES, RESTAURANT RECOVERY.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE HE IS!
MY FRIEND, ROB SCHNEIDER.
>> OH, MY GOOD!
>> TODD’S A BUDDY OF MINE --
>> OH, MY GOD, I CAN’T.
>> THIS FAMILY HAS BEEN
STRUGGLING SINCE THE PANDEMIC
STARTED.
>> I’M SORRY, WE’RE JUST --
>> AND ROB’S THE PERFECT GUY TO
HELP LIFT THEIR SPIRITS.
>> INCREDIBLE, RIGHT?
>> WE GREW UP, HE’S SUCH A
CULTURE ICON.
[LAUGHTER]
>> TODD KNOWS THIS BUSINESS MORE
THAN ANYBODY, AND HE’S HERE TO
HELP AND I’M HERE TO EAT.
[LAUGHTER]
LAWRENCE LAWRENCE TODD, I’VE GOT
TO ASK YOU BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
BACK IN TEXAS WE HAVE THESE
EVERYWHERE.
YOU GUYS PRIDE YOURSELF ON
CUSTOMER SERVICE AS WELL AND
SERVING THE PEOPLE.
ARE YOU TEACHING THE FOLKS,
THESE BUSINESSES HOW TO STEP UP
THEIR GAME IN THAT?
>> YEAH, WE DON’T -- I REALLY
DIDN’T HAVE TO FIX ANYTHING.
THESE WERE GREAT RESTAURANT THE
OWNERS, BUT COULDN’T HAVE
PREPARED FOR A PANDEMIC, RIGHT?
SO JUST THINK ABOUT THIS EPISODE
THAT ROB HELPED OUT, YOU KNOW,
OVERNIGHT THIS RESTAURANT LOST
ALL THEIR CUSTOMER BASE BECAUSE
THE UNIVERSITY BECAUSE IT WAS
SHUT DOWN.
OVERNIGHT THEY GO DOWN TO NOT
MUCH.
THEIR FOOD WAS AMAZING, AND ROB
LOVED IT.
HE MADE A GOOD POINT, HE SAID,
HEY, YOU NEED TO GET THIS FOOD
OUT TO PHOENIX.
THE GREATER PHOENIX AREA HAS 5
MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT WAS GETTING A DELIVERY
VEHICLE, AND THEN THEY ALSO HAD
A STORE AN AREA THEY WEREN’T
USING FOR ANYTHING, BUT THEY
WANTED TO LAWN ARE.
THIS CONCEPT -- LAUNCH THIS
CONCEPT CALLED CHAI CORNER WHICH
WAS A COFFEE HOUSE.
IT WAS A GREAT IDEA ESPECIALLY
BY CAMPUS.
THOSE TWO THINGS GOT THEM
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC, AND
THEY’RE DOING BETTER THAN THEY
EVER HAVE.
PETE: ROB -- GO AHEAD.
>> PART OF THAT TO SEE THEM --
BECAUSE THEY WERE AT THEIR
BOTTOM WHEN TODD CAME IN.
I MEAN, LITERALLY THEIR
CUSTOMERS NOT ONLY WERE THEY NOT
HAVING CUSTOMERS, THERE WAS ONLY
A LIMITED AMOUNT.
IT WAS ALL FOOD TO GO.
AND TO SEE THAT TURN AROUND WAS
REALLY HEART WARMING.
PETE: AND, ROB, ARE THEY -- DO
YOU SENSE THAT THEY’RE, YOU
KNOW, HOPEFUL THAT THEY’RE
COMING OUT OF IT AND THEY CAN
NOW COMPETE WITH THE RAISING
CANES OF THE WORLD?
>> OH, YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
THEY HAVE THEIR NICHE.
THEY WERE DOING WELL, BUT, LIKE,
THE STRUGGLE WAS GOING ON FOR SO
LONG, AND THEY WERE LITERALLY
PUTTING THEIR LIFE SAVINGS INTO
THIS.
AND ALSO THE KIDS WERE STOPPING
THEIR LIVES TO, YOU KNOW, TO
KEEP THIS GOING.
AND IT WAS JUST, IT WAS LOSING
MONEY EVERY MONTH AND HANG IN
THERE.
SO TODD WAS ABLE TO GO IN THERE
AND MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS AND
GET THEIR FOOD OUT TO, LIKE HE
SAID, TO OTHER PEOPLE IN OTHER
AREAS THROUGH THIS FOOD
TRANSPORTATION VEHICLE.
AND IT WAS ABLE TO -- I’M
TELLING YOU, TO SEE PEOPLE’S
DREAMS AND SEE THEM HAVE HOPE
AGAIN AND TO SEE THEM TURN
AROUND, IT’S SOMETHING ELSE.
I MEAN, YOU DON’T GET THE CHANCE
TO REALLY BE A PART OF THAT OR
SEE THAT.
I WAS JUST THERE TO EAT THE --
[LAUGHTER]
CHICKEN AND STUFF, AND IT’S
BEAUTIFUL FOOD.
THE STORIES OF THE PEOPLE, IT’S
HER MOTHER’S RECIPE AND HER
GRANDMA’S RECIPE, IT MAKES YOU
REALLY APPRECIATE FOOD AND
APPRECIATE CULTURE.
LAWRENCE: A BEAUTIFUL AMERICAN
STORY.
UNFORTUNATELY, GENTLEMEN, WE’VE
GOT TO SCOOT.
TODD THE, I’VE GOT TO ASK YOU
BEFORE WE LEAVE, WHEN IS NEW
YORK CITY GOING TO GET A RAISING
CANE?
>> I’M WORKING ON IT.
REAL ESTATE’S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFICULT THERE.
FUL.
[LAUGHTER]
LAWRENCE: I’LL BE CALLING YOU.
MAYBE WE CAN GET SOMETHING DONE
TOGETHER.
>> I’M GOING TO BRING A BAG FOR
YOU.
NOR.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THANK YOU, EVERYBODY.
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESS,
FAMILY-OWNED.
LET’S SUPPORT THEM.
SUPPORT THAT SMALL RESTAURANT,
SMALL BUSINESS.
>> IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD, YOU CAN
DO IT.
[LAUGHTER]
PETE: THAT’S WHAT WE NEEDED.
THAT’S WHAT WE WAS MISSING IN
THIS SEGMENT.
JEDEDIAH: THANK YOU BOTH FOR
BEING HERE, SO INSPIRING.
SO MUCH FUN.
AND RESTAURANT RECOVERY IS
STREAMING NOW OP ON DISCOVERY
PLUS.
YOU CAN WATCH ROB’S EPISODE ON